right now I'm driving downtown to go do
a rehearsal for frog university it's
happening tomorrow depending on when
you're watching it it might be happening
right now
and of course it's Los Angeles
[Music]
made it downtown to the convention
center we're about to head in and go
start setting up for tomorrow guys look
this is the banner vlog University is
here this is still exciting so
everything is still being set up for
tomorrow
this is our little they told me not to
film because it looks messy and this
isn't what its gonna look like but I was
like this is awesome logging this is
what we do we film the behind the scenes
but I want to show you guys this is what
I'm really excited about we have so much
fun
vlog you swag we have pink water bottles
they had a bunch of different colors but
as soon as I saw this hot pink I knew
immediately we needed this
locking pens we also have some tote bags
here's some of our sponsors so thank you
guys over here is one of the breakout
rooms we're gonna be having panels and
sessions and everything is not set up
yet I'm excited to see this tomorrow
it's gonna be a surprise to me because I
don't even know 100% what its gonna look
like we've seen pictures we've talked
about things but you never actually know
until the day of so you guys are gonna
get to see it was over here oh here's
another little room I just keep thinking
about how crazy it is that this whole
thing started from a little YouTube show
that I started 10 years ago there's
still tickets if you want to get them
online - make sure you check out vlog
University comm and we're gonna be here
all weekend so hope to see you guys
[Music]
red carpet we're gonna roll it out
do it for the gram or the tick-tock or
the bite
[Music]
[Music]
got the shop so here's the theater where
the keynotes gonna be happening I'm so
excited my friend Josh Sundquist who I'm
sure most of you guys know here on
YouTube he's incredible he's gonna be
also doing the keynote and I can't
believe it it's crazy because I met him
oh my gosh like at the first VidCon the
fact that he is now here doing the
keynote at vlogging university is so
great
[Music]
[Music]